(xylophone music)
Philip: People, what I would like to know
is the answer to a very simple question.
Are we alone, as conscious beings,
in this entire buzzing
400-billion star galaxy,
one of ten to the tenth other galaxies?
It seems pretty implausible.
Brit: The modern search
for extraterrestrial
intelligence, or SETI,
began in 1959, when
two Cornell physicists,
Giuseppe Cocconi and Philip Morrison,
published an article in Nature
that outlined the possibility
of using radio and microwaves
to communicate between the stars.
In order for this to work,
researchers assumed that
any intelligent civilization
will have discovered the ability
to transmit radio waves.
This assumption is based, in part,
on the fact that it took human beings
only 80 years to figure
out how to do this,
following Alessandro Volta's discovery
of batteries and electric current.
The premise is quite simple.
We can create radio waves by sending
short pulses of electric
current through wires.
These waves can then travel
beyond our atmosphere
and out through Space
with little interference.
Once these radio or electromagnetic waves
are sent out, they can be
received, using antennas,
and turned back into electrical pulses.
In 1960, Frank Drake
conducted the first search
for radio signals from
other solar systems.
Much like turning a radio dial,
Drake was trying to scan the sky
in order to tune in to faint radio signals
that might be coming from other worlds.
Though this first attempt did not result
in any noteworthy findings,
researchers have been scanning
the stars ever since.
Carl: So, there is some chance that,
in the next few decades,
we will get the signal
from some spectacularly distant,
spectacularly exotic civilization,
and everything on Earth will,
as a consequence,
change. That is possible.
Kent: The interesting
thing about the SETI search
is that, although we claim
that we're looking for
extraterrestrial intelligence,
we can't actually define
what an intelligent signal is, and so,
a starting point is to
say we look for a signal
which nature will not produce
by any mechanism that we understand.
Brit: An important question emerges.
How can we ever know
if such a signal is coming
from an intelligent source?
At the first SETI meeting, in 1961,
John Lilly proposed that researchers study
dolphin languages to help them learn more
about what extraterrestrial signals
might be like.
Much of this early work
culminated in the research
conducted by Laurance R Doyle
and Brenda McCowan.
Doyle and McCowan's work
is based on the assumption that,
if there is some common
trait, in both human
and non-human communication systems,
then extraterrestrial
communication systems
should also share this trait.
They analyzed a long
sequence of vocalizations
from both adult and baby
humans, and dolphins,
and, in the case of dolphins,
this was a set of whistles and clicks.
Now, human babies learn to speak
(baby babbles)
through a process
of vocal imitation,
slowly amassing a larger
and larger set of sound signals.
Baby in green top: (babbling)
Brit: However, during what is
known as the babbling phase,
the sounds produced
are more or less random
or unstructured. To see
this, Doyle and McCowan
plotted the different sound signals
against their frequency,
or how often they occur,
then they ordered the symbols
in the graph according to frequency,
with the most common symbols on the left
and the least common on the right.
With human babies, the
slope is nearly level
as all sound signals produced
occur fairly evenly or randomly.
However, as children learn the language
of their parents, they
narrow their sound repertoire
to fit the model to
which they are exposed,
Boy green top: Ah, eh, eh, oo.
Brit: structure is imposed
on our speech patterns.
Consequently, the slope of this graph
converges towards a 45 degree angle,
or a negative one slope
on a log-log chart.
This is known as Zipf's Law.
What's interesting is that this same slope
appears in different human languages
and seems to be a
pattern all humans share.
Even more surprising is that this pattern
also emerged when Doyle and McCowan
analyzed non-human communication.
They found that the whistle sounds
produced by baby dolphins
seemed to be distributed
in a pattern similar to human babies
during the babbling phase.
At first, the dolphin whistles
are more or less unstructured,
and, by the time they reach adulthood,
the graph converges on a slope
of about negative one,
which is the same as humans.
(dolphin whistles and clicks)
This sort of analysis looks
only at individual signals
or words and doesn't say anything
about the deeper linguistic structure
of either human or dolphin
communication systems.
Let's clarify what we mean
by deeper structure with an example.
If I select a random word from a book
and ask you to guess what it is,
you will have no clue what it might be
and will have to simply guess.
If, instead, I give you
a random word from a book
and ask you to predict
the word that follows it,
you will still have to guess.
However, you'll notice it's likely easier
to guess this word and,
if I give you a sequence
of two words from a book,
and ask you to predict
the third word, it becomes
more predictable still,
and, if you are given a
sequence of three words,
this trend continues; the ability to guess
is even easier. It seems that,
as a result of the structure of language,
the freedom of choice decreases
as we look at longer and
longer strings of words.
Intuitively, this is why we can finish
each other's sentences.
Now, to quantify this, Doyle and McCowan
borrowed Claude Shannon's
measure of entropy,
which, as you recall, is
a measure of surprise.
Entropy can be thought of as the number
of yes or no questions, or bits,
required to guess the next word,
so, as predictability increases,
the information entropy decreases,
and Doyle and McCowan
calculated the entropy for
different depths or orders,
so, single words is first order,
groups of two words is second order,
groups of three words is third order,
and so on, and then they plotted
the value of information entropy
against this depth and, for adult humans,
as we may expect, they found
that the information entropy decreases
as the depth increases,
and this is a result of the rule structure
in our communication systems.
Amazingly, Doyle and
McCowan did the same thing
with dolphin languages and
found the same pattern.
Dolphin communication systems display
decreasing information entropy
as we look at longer
sequences of sound signals.
This means that, in dolphin
communication systems,
there is a rule structure which emerges
and, arguably, this also allows dolphins
to finish each other's sentences too.
(dolphin whistles and clicks)
Now contrast this to
just a random sequence
of symbols which has a flat line
on this information entropy graph,
since there is no conditional dependence
between symbols. Now, because this pattern
emerges in both human and non-human
communication systems, Doyle and McCowan
have suggested that this
decreasing of entropy
is essential for the transmission
of what we might call knowledge.
As Doyle puts it, "If we
get a narrow band signal,
"a negative one slope on the Zipf plot,
"and higher order Shannon entropies,
"we've nailed it."
and all of this rests on a simple premise
that aliens, too, can finish
each other's sentences.
Man in film: How can I help
you to communicate with us?
Alien in film: Now I am able to speak
by assimilation, a form of photosynthesis.
I have been able to incorporate
certain of Dr [Wyman's]
functional processes.
Man in film: Was Dr
Wyman's death necessary?
Alien in film: Through his sacrifice,
I can communicate.
Brit: Without even
understanding the language
or culture of the other
human or non-human species,
Claude Shannon's entropy
is a unit of measure
that can allow us to detect the presence
of these structural rules,
regardless of meaning.
Claude Shannon's model of information
was borne out of a desire to save time
over the telegraph wires,
and this led to the global
unit of information,
the bit, a single difference,
now the backbone of our
information economy.
The increasingly digital
and network technologies
that drive our modern
world point to the power
and persistence of Claude Shannon's ideas.
The bit is here to stay,
and the study of information theory
will continue to play a key role
in our technological
and social innovations,
on Earth and, perhaps, beyond.
Carl: I think even if
there's a plausible argument
for a few, we've got to keep looking.
I'd even go further than that.
If there's a plausible argument
that there isn't anybody out there,
bearing in mind that we can be wrong,
we ought to keep looking,
because the question
is of the most supreme importance.
It calibrates our place in the Universe.
It tells us who we are, and so,
it is worthwhile trying to
find other civilizations,
so, I would say no matter what.